bonjour à tous en en quelques mots et
donc de manière synthétique je voudrais
tout d'abord rendre un hommage appuyé à
l'ensemble des conseillers nationaux des
responsables départementaux des jeunes
des secrétaires départementaux des
présidents de fédérations des militants
de cette grande famille des républicains
qui jour après jour oeuvre sur le
terrain parce que c'est vous vous êtes
la famille des républicains et vous
pouvez vous applaudir quelques mots sur
ce bilan que vous connaissez christian
estrosi l'a dit avec beaucoup
d'efficacité nous savons à travers la
double peine qui nous est infligée au
quotidien que ce soit sur l'échiquier
national ou dans nos treize régions
combien le bilan socialiste n'est pas
mauvais le bilan socialiste dans nos
régions comme au niveau national est
catastrophique
il est catastrophique sur la fiscalité
sur la sécurité sur la dépense publique
sur le chômage sur la dette
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge et
nous disposons à quelques 30 jours du
premier tour des élections régionales
mes chers amis d'une opportunité
historique c'est d'entamer la grande
renaissance dont notre pays a besoin
cette renaissance elle passe tout
d'abord par l'unité comment
pourrions-nous prétendre rassemblé
quelques 60 millions de français
si nous n'étions pas capables en amont
de nous rassembler nous mêmes et c'est
toute la réussite de nicolas sarkozy que
d'avoir permis de rassembler les
républicains
les centristes les chasseurs et tant
d'autres à la veille de cette élection
l'unité le rassemblement sont des
conditions nécessaires à notre victoire
mais ne sont pas des conditions
suffisantes
nous devrons par delà les mesures
concrètes et crédibles que nous
présenterons les uns et les autres dans
nos régions
incarner des valeurs les valeurs de la
droite et la droite des valeurs
retrouver la fierté d'être français la
fierté d'être de droite et de nous
réconcilier avec les valeurs d'autorité
d'efforts de travail et de mérite car
tel est le bilan de la gauche
quel est le plus grand mal français mes
chers amis quand c'est malheureusement
plus compliqué que cela encore mais il
ya du vrai mais il ya du vrai quand vous
ne faites en france aucun effort quand
vous refusez systématiquement les mains
tendues par la société et par notre pays
vous êtes hélas systématiquement
encourager accompagner subventionné
excusé quant à l' inverse
vous travaillez vous faites des efforts
surtout quand vous venez
comme c'est mon cas d'une famille
modeste alors vous êtes suspecté
contrôle et fiscalisé
c'est tout le mal français que cet
assistanat qui gangrène le pacte
républicain et face à l'assistanat
nous devrons réhabiliter la méritocratie
à la française
alors pour conclure oui je le dis avec
l'ensemble des 89 colistiers de la
région centre val de loire avec les
quelques les quelques 2000 candidats de
notre famille politique
vous savez que c'est de notre région
qu'est né il y après ça il ya 500 ans
précisément la première grande et belle
renaissance à travers le règne de
françois 1er
l'arrivée en france de léonard de vinci
et de tant d'autres
eh bien ces deux cette renaissance dont
il nous faut parler la renaissance qui
avait de la france son jardin n'est pas
simplement une époque la renaissance
doit redevenir pour chacune et pour
chacun d'entre nous un caractère un mode
de vie une volonté un art de vivre
la renaissance pour incarner
l'alternance et l'espérance dont notre
pays a besoin
la renaissance doit redevenir une
politique
vive la république et vive les
républicains